افادت وسائل الاعلام الروسيه ان الرئيس
فلادمير بوتن زار جسر القرن الذي دمر
جزئيا في تشرين الاول اكتوبر الماضي
زياره تفقديه للجسر من داخل سياره يقودها
بنفسها
معناه دنيا
اخر خبر في هذه النشره وزياره الرئيس
بوتين الى الجسر مغزى ذلك ومن الذي حدث
ما اعلنه لكريم للجمال هو ان الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين قاد سياره بنفسه
على جسر القرم وتفقد اعمال الصيانه
الجاريه فيه وكان هناك كلام نقل عن بوتا
بحسب المتحدث باسم الكريم بوتن قال جمله
اساسيه قال انه يجب تامين جميع الطرق
البريه التي تصل روسيا بشبه جزيره القرم
اولا الزياره ترافقت مع تهديدات اوكرانيه
بانها بان شبه جزيره القرم ليس بمنئه عن
العمليات العسكريه وان وضعنا ما قاله بوتل
في السياق جسر القرم هو ليس الطريق الوحيد
الذي يصل بين الاراضي الروسيه وبين شبه
جزيره القرم اذا اخذنا بعين الاعتبار
الاستفتاء الذي اجرته روسيا قبل اسابيع في
عدد من المناطق الاوكرانيه منها
طرق اخرى بريه تصل الاراضي الروسيه
همم شبه جزيره القرم منها ما يمر بمقاطعتي
ذا بروسيا وخيرسون خاصه تلك المناطق التي
تقع حاليا تحت السيطره الاوكرانيه وضع
كلام بوتين في السياق يعني ان هناك تصميم
روسي ربما على محاوله استعاده المناطق
التي خسرتها سواء فيزا بروسيا او في خرسان
في خرسان تحديدا هذا هو المغزى من زياره
بوتين وهذه هي الدلاله التي فهمتمت طبعا
من هذه الزياره يريد بوتن ان يعطي احاء
بان جسر القرن باتبي من عن عن الضربات
الاوكرانيه الجسر هذا كما ذكر جمال تم
استهدافه في الثامن من اكتوبر تشرين الاول
الماضي بما قالت روسيا انه شاحنه مفخخه
وفي ذلك الوقت اتهمت السلطات الروسيه جهاز
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه بتدبير ذلك
هو انه اليوم شهد الدونيات قصف يمكن ان
نقول بانه مكثف وتقول السلطات المحليه ان
المدينه مدينه دنيتك التي تعتبر عاصمه
الانفصاليين في اقليم دونيت
تعرضت خلال الاسبوع الماضي بهاجمات تصفها
السلطات بانها الاعنف منذ بدايه الحرب في
اوكرانيا او ما تصفها روسيا العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا واشير اخيرا الى ان
القصف في هذه الاثناء يتجدد وهو في
الحقيقه قصف متبادل تقصف القوات
الاوكرانيه وسط وبعض احياء مدينه دنيتك
ويكون الرد من قبل الجانب الروسي على بعض
مناطق تمركز القوات الاوكرانيه خاصه في
ارضك ومناطق اخرى شكرا لك